[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT GAUNT: I remember
it was not long ago--
I think it was probably a
couple days ago-- the last time
that you did a
screenshot for a tweet.
And like whatever tweet the
was, people didn't care.
They were just like,
what's that thing?
ADDY OSMANI: That's
my daily living,
tweeting pictures of things.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, but don't
care about the content.
ADDY OSMANI: They don't.
MATT GAUNT: They just want to
know what theme you're using.
Like what theme are
you using right now?
ADDY OSMANI: So the
theme that I love using
the most is called Seti_UI.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, OK.
ADDY OSMANI: And
it's really nice.
It's got like really
nice vibrant colors
for pretty much all
different types of syntax.
And it's also got an
accompanying set of icons
for different file types.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah,
I love the icons.
I used that at one point.
It's really nice.
ADDY OSMANI: And one of the
nice things about Seti_UI
is that it's now available
for like Atom editor, Sublime.
I think Brackets
has also got it.
WebStorm has got
a version of it.
And you can also now get
it for your terminal,
which is kind of neat, too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]